اعلنت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه مقتله
واصابه عدد من المدنيين وتضرور منشات
مدنيه وبنى تحتيا نتيجه هجمات صاروخيه على
الاراضي الاوكرانيه
القوات الروسيه بقصف الاراضي الاوكرانيه
بسبعه صواريخ وعشرات الغارات الجويه
ومخذوفات من رجمات الصواريخ الاركان ان
خطوط المواجهه بين الطرفين شهدت 35
اشتباكا كما نفذ الطيران الاوكراني سبعه
عشره غاره على مواقع القوات الروسيه وتم
قصف منظومات صواريخ مضاده للطيران هذا
واكلت هيئه الاركان ان قواتها تواصل صدى
الهجمات الروسيه في مقاطعتي خاركاف
والدنيا بينما تواصل القوات الاوكرانيه
هجومها في مقاطعه زباروجيا ضمن محوري
وعن عمليه الانزال الخاصه التي نفذها جهاز
الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه نقلت وسائل
الاعلام روسيه عن استخبارات موسكو ان
عمليه الانزال افشلت بقتل جميع الجنود
المشاركين وكان المتحدث باسم جهاز
الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه اندريوس قد قال ان
عمليه الانزال الخاصه تلك التي نفذها
الجهاز بالتعاون مع القوات البحريه في شبه
جزيره القرم الليله الماضيه قد اسفرت عن
مقتل 30 جنديا روسيا وتدمير كذلك اربعه
زوارق روسيه
اهميه العمليات الخاصه وانزال عناصر
الاستطلاع في شبه جزيره القرم تكمن في ان
الناس باتوا يؤمنون بانتصارنا ليس فقط في
البر الرئيسي لاوكرانيا ولكن ايضا في شبه
جزيره القرم علينا ان نتذكر ونؤمن بان
النصر ليس بعيدا وان تحرير سكان شبه جزيره
القرم ليس بعيدا سننفذ ضربات في شبه جزيره
القرم ولن ينتهي كل شيء عند هذا الحد
سنستعيد اراضينا وقريبا سيعود جميع من
ينتظر التحرير الى دياره